ammazza adesso perfetto vai ce la possa
fare
ci credo non sia noi che sangue cioè
fantastico l'ho ammazzata così
dichiarato professionismo e di adesso
non ha prima corsa non mi notava la zia
bella le fan culo va si no oddio che
capelli e meglio loro bellissimo
[Risate]
[Musica]
apriti e vabbè lo sapevo che non si
apriva dovuto riparla ragazzi provo non
sono sicuro che bel culo che ciò non vi
spaventate sono l'insegnante di
stretching della prof
cioè la sto aiutando a prepararsi con la
lezione non fare quella faccia zio di
andare a studiare tornare ma don levi
levarti non tifare mia madre perché vado
da selena gomez diventa mia moglie fa
parte la mia famiglia abbiamo per sempre
in culo tutti capito ma e la morte che
dà valore alla vita fa vj e la vita che
dà valore alla andiamo avanti
video io sentii tranquilli venite tutti
e chi è quello che manca non importa noi
andiamo via ciao
andiamo ragazzi ogni caso mai c'era una
roba no vabbè ma
un posticino non male neanche volendo
posso giocare a sta roba ma di che cazzo
stiamo a parlare se ce l'ho fatta e non
fai qui alla stanza ma è prodotta
cogliano soddisfatto oggi fatto
mascherato o catturato gli indigeni
mamma sei sicura che questa scena sia
commestibile perché non l'ha detto ma tu
lo sai che se primo gif al drop aiuta
[Musica]
cosa ho fatto qualcosa fanno bene basta
ciao
basta un po di pre io ti tira il caso
dietro l'altra mano una passatina
passettino passantino veloce quanto
storica traianei e che la di davanti che
cazzo mi fa venire il nervoso quando lo
vedo che si piegano le stoppie a
raddrizzarlo mia famiglia il nervoso si
piega e non riesco più a raddrizzare
frega
ok ma non ho fatto ma anche in tempo a
fan pazzo mi è saltato in bocca
no no queste sono cose sporche signor
trap non possiamo farla in pubblico
perché si stava masturbando sul mio
ginocchio signor trump
ma io
papà
dai che buona
all.re un g8 che sei vicino alle 9 erano
chiusi scarpe si è aperta porca [ __ ]
veloce
ecco il primo attrezzo questa cosa fa
malissimo preferirei la morte
preferirei decisamente la morte però
almeno è sugli hamburger non credo serva
il ketchup
allora a questo punto poi non lo so
[Musica]
crederci
anche a [ __ ] che vittoria nuova patch a
one questa operazione di lusso prevede
anche un taglio dei capelli quindi stia
tranquillo si rilassi che procedono a
non vorreste vedere questa cosa quindi
non me la faccio vedere o quello si
chiama mohamed amena ma non a tutti
no no no no no dai
le giraffe sono delle cattive persone
no sono animali sono fai gol creature
senza cuore
sono le giraffe sono gay sono non
sinceri fantastico io amo le giraffe
meravigliosa questa risposta basato
sugli alieni qualcosa mi dice che così
però non ne sono completamente convinto
adesso vediamo se riesco a convincerlo
poi succederà è più il già qualcuno mi
sono kakà tissimo bisogno il trasporto
davvero cosa sta facendo coi piedi no
che verso il caffè ma non ci arrivo però
ti puzza madre
ma fa ancora quanto e sexy quest'uomo
armi pari il nino non decerebrato ma
veramente [ __ ] prima della
suddetta l'uscita del sottoscritto
alquanto vero ma subito
ecco qua e commentati che abbiamo fatto
e di dischi lim come avevamo e di cosa
dischi ma non ho capito di scream
non è che me lo ripeti un'altra volta di
chi perfetto
noi amici cosa non capisci la parola
fermo zio fai parlare ma che io sono
bravo le persone anche ai can't make you
stronger ai will give you are my mia
cagato di street
allora sarei la persona più ricca e
famosa del mondo ma morirai di droga tra
vent'anni ci sta quinta come ci sta
ma che cosa ci sta quella da dove è
uscita ma chi è
[Applauso]
io non ti ho fatto niente bella
simpatica un paio di trucchi da chicoli
[ __ ]
grazie a dio che mi insegna che di
quella [ __ ] minchia bruttissimo ma mai
preso il fatto così da una vita
ve lo ricordate ragazzi di cartone di
hercules quando hercules e taglia le
teste al tipo a quel coso lì enorme
eccolo fare la stessa cosa ragazzi se
riesco e per l'amor di dio non è
esattamente andata così per alcune
funzioni guarda che ci vogliono forte le
provviste di amazon bastardi bastardi
[Risate]
sì però dovete farvi cattivo bravissimo
[Musica]
e shelley trasformata in zona di shrek è
vero il problema quello in obesità
quindi devo danneggiare i tubi questi
zona bastarda me l'aspettavo mai nella
vita
[Musica]
quanto bello questo video ma vabbè
comunque non sono non sono una persona
che si autoelogia per ora proprio bello
ragazzi miei spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto è passato tipo quasi un
anno dall'ultimo momenti epici che ho
fatto
ogni anno che passa è veramente diventa
sempre più bello quindi mi aspetto che
il 2017 si ancora più divertente per me
per voi poi c'è anche o ridere il
massimo con cui a prescindere con quei
grazie ragazzi per tutti i risultati
abbiamo raggiunto quest'anno perché
sembra tra i milioni e 300 mila iscritti
che non sono sicuro di sapere come si
scriva però grazie e niente serve verde
puzza proprio di merda i ragazzi spero
che questo video vi sia piaciuto quel
momento è un mi piace e condividete con
la nonna e non mi piace anche i vari
social che cosa era invitato ton
descrizione dei desideri ci vediamo al
prossimo video e ragazzi schiacciato no
porca put non subì schiaccia i
telecomandi cioè offrite